le soleil a chassé la grisaille abbé
Saint-Paul après la consternation
l'heure est à la solidarité
de voir tout le monde qui s'affaire à
gauche à droite puis de voir que tout le
monde a coeur
dans les quartiers les plus endommagés
par les inondations les bénévoles ne
sont pas ça fait plaisir de vous
l'organisation du Festif de
Baie-Saint-Paul c'est porté volontaire
pour coordonner les efforts sur le
terrain aujourd'hui plus d'une centaine
de citoyens ont répondu à l'appel on
sait pas encore où on va être dépêché
mais on a une pelle on a des bottes on
peut servir à quelque chose
les entrepreneurs aussi mettent la main
à la pâte
apocalyptique c'est pas mal pire qu'on
pensait que ça se limite au sous-sol
mais finalement c'est l'eau est monté à
un pied dans maison c'est mon Galarneau
a offert gratuitement les services de
son entreprise de construction aux
propriétaires de cette résidence c'est
notre contribution un petit peu à la
communauté
Roux a emménagé à Baie-Saint-Paul il y a
un an avec sa jeune famille pour elle
c'est un coup de pouce inestimable puis
en fait aujourd'hui ce qu'on aurait pas
fait en trois semaines ce qu'on n'aurait
pas été capable puis c'est moi hier je
craquais parce que je voyais pas le but
puis aujourd'hui je suis vraiment
positive sont duplexe fait partie des
186 logements qui ne peuvent toujours
pas être réintégrés quatre jours après
les inondations mais les lents de
solidarité lui donnent espoir même si le
nettoyage avance la reconstruction sera
longue ici sur la rue des Cèdres
certains résidents disent déjà qu'ils
veulent démolir pour ne plus jamais
revivre un tel désastre tout va dépendre
de l'aide financière qui leur sera
offerte ici Camille Carpentier
Radio-Canada